I think that the revolution in
neuroscience is sort of happening in two
fronts one is the study of epigenetics
and the best way to think of the
epigenome is that if the our genomes our
DNA is the hardware of a computer our
epigenome is the software so it's
actually sort of telling our DNA how it
should be expressed how much of a
particular protein should be expressed
at what time during our life and the
epigenome is heavily influenced by our
environment and not just our environment
our parents environment and their
parents environment some of the software
programs are so embedded that they make
these changes that last for generations
others for just a small period of time
so the revolution is really coming in
understanding that there is no more
nature versus nurture debate nature and
nurture are intertwined they're really
impossible to separate and as we look at
our study of brain and behavior we need
to understand that there is no behavior
there is no biology outside of the
environment and then the second point I
think in neuroscience for a long time
we've been gender blind so many studies
for many reasons have only focused on
males of the species or have not
compared men and women and they haven't
compared male and female brains and
although it's quite controversial and
for whatever reason people want to take
different to mean smarter or better I
don't think that we can ignore anymore
that male and female brains have certain
circuits that are sexually dimorphic the
same way that we have downstairs regions
that are different we have some upstairs
regions that are different as well and
moving forward in the study of
neuroscience we're gonna have to really
pay attention to the fact that there are
these differences to understand what
they mean for behavior
you